So you've been thinking of slope as
vertical change over horizontal change
and that's exactly what slope is.
And we've been using the words rise and
run.
And the way we've been finding
the slope, is by looking at a line, and
finding two points.
Let's say in this case 0,0 and,
I don't know, 2,4.
And then we've been finding the rise and
the run by actually counting, 1, 2,
3, 4 is my rise, and 1, 2 is my run.
So this would have a slope of 4 over 2,
which I guess is 2, and
that's fine, that works.
But what if we don't have
the image of the line itself?
How can I get the slope then?
Well, what we want to do is come up
with a mathematical method of taking two
points like 2,4 and 0,0.
And somehow getting the slope from them,
and luckily exactly this method exists.
Now we typically use the letter
m to stand for slope,
and please don't ask me why I have
no idea what m has to do with slope.
But the equation we have two points
looks something like this y2 minus y1
over x2 minus x1.
And these little 2s and 1s are called
subscripts, and what do they mean?
Well, these 2s mean we're referring
to our second point, and the 1s,
mean we're referring to the first point.
So this would be the y coordinate of the
first point, the x coordinate the first
point, x coordinate the second,
and y coordinate the second.
And I'm going to show you how I would
use this equation with these points.
So here, our first point was this one
here, 0,0 though in truth it doesn't
matter which we call first and
which we call second.
And your second point
was this one here 2,4.
And since I said x1 was the x
coordinate of the first point,
it corresponds to that 0.
Ad y1 is the y coordinate
of the first point,
corresponds to that 0,
x2 is this 2, and y2 is this 4.
And so to use this equation to calculate
the slope, I would say m equals
y2 which is 4, minus y1 which is 0,
over x2 which is 2,
minus x1, which is 0.
Which is just 4 over 2, or 2,
and this makes a lot of sense.
The numerator over here y2 minus y1,
well that's just the change here,
the vertical change.
And x2 minus x1,
that's this horizontal change.
So why don't you practice now?
What's the slope of a line that
goes to the points 3,2 and, 5,5.
Enter your answer here, numerator and
denominator in these boxes.